well despite those warnings not to
travel this holiday weekend there
are still travelers heading to las vegas
let's take a look at our traffic cam
from prim that's at the state line
between nevada and california
traffic was pretty heavy throughout the
afternoon very steady
not nearly the crowds we typically would
see heading into a long weekend but
still plenty of headlights headed our
way brian
yes and today typically one of the
busiest days to travel by car and by
plane
aaa expecting a drop in travel though
joe moeller spoke to some who are out on
the roadways and freeways today
he's live near i-15 in the area of
silverado ranch
with a bit more hi joe
hey there brian if you've traveled the
day before thanksgiving you know it can
be a nightmare well this year it is
different just like everything else in
2020. here's a live look at the 15 here
at this hour traffic is moving slowly
we're just
right next to the south point here
traffic has been
moving pretty nicely throughout the
evening since we've been out here we did
talk to a few travelers earlier who did
say they still feel safe hitting the
roads
catch any traffic going here people
traveling to the las vegas area by car
for thanksgiving say it was a smooth
ride
we actually didn't expect to be at this
location at this hour
we did not see too many on the road
actually we drove through last night
and it wasn't too bad no it wasn't as
bad as it's been
the seven magic mountains proved to be a
popular spot wednesday
as cove 19 cases rise around the nation
states like nevada are recommending
people stay home
states like california do have travel
restrictions in place
aaa expects the 10 drop in travel people
say they felt safe
we haven't eaten out at all except for
the drive-through
and just trying to be extra careful
wearing our mask two and a half million
are expected to fly
mccarron has extra safety protocols in
place only ticketed passengers are
allowed inside everyone's wearing their
mask and even the flight attendants make
them put it on if they're not so
i feel like we're safe people flying
into las vegas say copen 19 did cross
their mind but it did not stop them from
seeing their family
lines were very short things moved you
know smoothly
got to the gate that was fine the flight
was the same everybody was still like
close together so that was pretty crazy
but
other than that it was pretty pretty
regular mccarran is asking people to
arrive and park early due to the extra
safety measures
in place
not back out here live you're taking
another look at the 15 here traffic
moving smoothly although the cdc is not
recommending travel during the holiday
nevada's statewide pause and not
implement
any new travel restrictions so you are
urged to take precautions if you
are traveling reporting live phil mohler
8 news now